greetings from podcastville it's
wednesday the 19th of august
i'm in jerseys hopefully but anyway the
church is brought to you by
manscaped listen like you saw in the
video manscap is dedicated to helping
you take care of all your hair from your
butt to your [ __ ] nut
and now they just released the shears
2.0 nail kit it's flip-flop season
[ __ ]
nobody wants to see that [ __ ] fungi
toenail i hate it going to jiu jitsu why
because people got to see my toenail i
would have to put a [ __ ] band-aid on
it and they believe i cut it i had
band-aids on three [ __ ] toenails
so listen take care of your [ __ ]
toenails they're disgusting
the shears are the perfect add-on to the
lawnmower they're like dirty cousins
once you got your stinky balls hair in
order you got to make sure those hands
and feet are as smooth as uncle joey's
[ __ ] nut sack
so do yourself a favor right now go to
right now go to manscape.com i'm going
to give you 20
off and free shipping with code church
20. you heard that church 20
manscape.com i'm going to give you 20
off with free shipping
at manscape use church you use code
church 20. summer's here it's time to
trim up
with manscape your nuts your fingernails
everything what happens when you finger
bang somebody you're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
up their uterus whatever the [ __ ] it is
trim your toenails and your fingers
[ __ ] go to manscape.com
do yourself a favor and get the right
tools for the job it's wednesday
it's time to get serious kick this
[ __ ] mule lee
oh [ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today all
right no more [ __ ] excuses this is
the year
of the [ __ ] soldier we're going in
like [ __ ] marines
welcome to church [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's wednesday with down to bad
bones in this [ __ ] studio
look at this it's like a [ __ ]
detention center in here i wouldn't want
it any other way honestly
you come into a room like this usually
you see mexican kids wrapped up in
aluminum foil and [ __ ]
i'm saying but it's just us today it's
wednesday
uh in the studio is my man david schuler
if you love
listen let me tell you the [ __ ] story
all right just so you [ __ ]
knuckleheads knock it the [ __ ] off right
because it's getting it it's just it
never ends it never ends it never ends
never ends
and i think covert is making people
dumber i think that's because i'm
getting dumb as [ __ ] i'm getting done
forgetting [ __ ]
yeah forgetting lunches yeah you know
it's viral you take a shower you don't
shave yeah they took a shower and i went
into the shade i came out it looked like
[ __ ] gunga then
what the [ __ ] did i take a shower for it
was the shade and i forgot the [ __ ]
shave
david schuler is a composer songwriter
two-time grammy-nominated
pink you know [ __ ] john legend the
whole [ __ ] deal
so i like music guys you know i don't
know about you [ __ ]
you know lee i was raised on disco i
don't give a [ __ ] i like music all right
i like all types of music
donna summer pavarotti it's
it's art it's art i appreciate it uh
you know the only thing i don't like is
that rigatoni music that [ __ ] will drive
that [ __ ] drives me [ __ ] bananas but
beside that you got my attention
everywhere else uh
when i came you know when we started
this podcast i wanted to show you guys
where i came from
i wanted to show you the iron maidens
with the original singer paul diana
yeah i wanted to show you judas priest
even though but this thing is gay what
he's a bad [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] he sucks nickel he's success
he's he's still singing he's saying
whatever he sings great so whatever he's
sucking you better get to it
because you can't sing you know what i'm
saying at least the gay guy can say you
know i just
i just grew up listening to spanish
music
you know soul music [ __ ] gospel music
i always gave everything a chance
yeah so when we came on the podcast
mondays was always tony bennett our
respect for the spirits
and then we'd turn on different songs
and blah blah blah but youtube would
flag us
for sure youtube busting [ __ ]
yep uh
youtube you know every two weeks i get a
[ __ ] red
i go on my google emails and i get 20
[ __ ] copyright infringement yeah
[ __ ] youtube and people don't get it
that you want to play music if it was up
to me i'd play [ __ ] just music and
talk about it and [ __ ]
nope you know i do these videos at night
they're done because i play music
yeah like when i just anything led
zeppelin claimed it already boom
yep gone that's it even on patreon yeah
no not on patreon on
youtube they they yank your videos if
you play music so
instagram is starting to do it yeah
people just don't get it uh
russell peters was here yep and he said
one night he was doing instagram live he
was djing
yeah they shut them down and they'll
donate
you know you get these emails
what's your favorite sparkling song how
old are we 13.
i sparked anything what is wrong with
you who raised you
who asked these types of questions yeah
like
what what do you listen to when you get
high when i'm pissing
in the morning a [ __ ] song pops into
my [ __ ] head
and whatever that song is as i'm making
coffee i'm getting fired up you know
and it could be anything it's just
something i'm thinking about and it
could be somebody like it could be a
shitty band
somebody i'm not even into you know
today i listen to heaven tonight
i don't like [ __ ] cheap trick wow
correct me
heaven tonight nobody remembers heaven
tonight
everybody knows cheap trick live from
buda con yep i just want to hear heaven
tonight
i couldn't put it out because people
don't like that type of music yeah
they're going to go
you know what is this joey nobody's
heard of that side of cheap trick
sure you know so you can't that's what i
felt like listening to that's when i
woke up boom boom i
had to be the movers were coming over at
[ __ ] nine
so i got up and was ready for movies and
the thing was supposed to get there
yesterday
and it never showed so my wife was
driving me crazy all [ __ ] at night
are they gonna show are they on the show
she kept going outside
pull your car in the driveway take it
out of the driveway i almost [ __ ]
stabbed i had to get the gun and go out
there 10 times in and out with the
[ __ ] gun
because there's creepy people listen
there was a guy last night
at 12 30. i saw him i saw him
i went outside to pull the car out some
guy
would like a thong on on a skateboard
huh dogs three times ago dog
if i would have had a net i would have
chased him
and [ __ ] and put him in the net like
if i would have had a hole like i'm
telling you i'm up to a different
this cobia doesn't even make me [ __ ]
with flies no more i'm ready to torture
a human like put them in the hole like
that dude that the dude did the chubby
chicks and silence of the lambs
oh you put the like that dude just wants
to be in a hole
yeah like that dude skateboarding or you
were so is 13. it wasn't a thong what
was it what do you call those
bikini shorts speedo speed up yeah let's
be there well 30. it sounds like it
sounds like it's bert
do i need that no i need that if i was
me
20 years ago i would have run that guy
over but now you got cameras you got
satellites you got dents
they look at the body shop i'll run them
over take it to an armenian body shop
they'll never find that [ __ ] car
again you understand me you know you're
like a vigilante superhero i can't stand
no more how can you have a [ __ ]
speedo on what if you fall you're gonna
straighten your knees
yeah i ride a bike i get jeans on like a
soldier you think i wanna
ride a bike with jeans no but i'm not
scraping my knees like some [ __ ]
hooker who got caught giving a [ __ ]
behind an alley in the chinese ship
kicks her in the stomach now she's got
bloody knees anyway so
my point is oh we need new music uh
one of my agents contacted me and he
said that one of his good friends from
rochester
is a bad [ __ ] and he uh put a
song together for us and
now the song that you hear when the
church comes on was
put together by my man mr david schuler
that's it he read into my heart he put
everything i
he is a smart man see he listened to
everything i put on he goes i'm going to
find something in between that
we got the chick we got the machine gun
we got everything
yeah first of all we got [ __ ] we
got [ __ ] you know these are
things that come from my heart you
understand me
they live in my heart [ __ ] those
type of words
and then you blow my mind because you
you do something that i always have
wondered
like just now i was driving over here
and
it was one of prince's early hits i want
to be uh
love uh one that's probably my favorite
princess and he wrote that yeah
as because he was in love with patrice
russia a lot like that was his way of
giving it to patrice russian whatever
you know yep saying me
forget me yeah yeah [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] do i sit down you know what
i'm in love with the white chick at the
weed store you know she's a cute little
girl right
like if i was to be a [ __ ] young stud
like if i was 24 i would ask that girl
out
but how would i write a song sure how
would i write a [ __ ] song for a girl
i wanted to [ __ ]
i don't even know where to start i have
a hard time writing jokes that's why
music
has always been very interesting to me i
love
the music and reading about how it came
to be
how yeah somebody woke up to stephen
tyler
playing uh the piano to
dream on something like that and he said
keep playing that yeah
you know how does it work give me the
system from a to z
i mean man i feel like i can imagine
it's probably similar to
writing jokes in the sense that you know
every joke
kind of happens in a different way i bet
you know it comes from some
place um i mean the the medium is
different because
you know you have to you're speaking
through not only with lyrics of course
with your words but
you're trying to make instruments say
what you're trying to say
with your vocabulary right so you know
just knowing it
in the context of this show i've been
listening for years
i know the [ __ ] that you would play at
the top of the show
you know the tony bennett thing was
obviously like it was a tradition
but i grew up you know like i when i
first started playing guitar when i was
12 or 13 years old
um you know i was listening to kill them
all and and
and justice for all that was the [ __ ]
that i loved
i was convinced when i was a teenager
that when i'm when i mastered every
metallica song
that i would be happy so i did i mean i
i like it was like
guitar playing for me came first um and
then i hit that level where i was like
i feel like i can do everything i wanted
to do with guitar but
now i want to go somewhere else with it
so then i started
like really studying other genres of
music you know just the tradition
behind country songs and the songwriting
craft
um and i'd be going you know i was in
bands and [ __ ]
we were all you know my friends and i
we'd be making just the [ __ ] worst
music you've ever heard in your life
and we'd go into the studio and we'd pay
studios for demos
and we'd always come out now we were in
rochester so the studios were few and
far between
but we'd be paying for studio time and
we'd never be happy with
what we left with so that sort of led to
me wanting to learn how to produce
how to engineer how to get in the studio
and not only
take the song that i've written and was
ready to record but learn how to record
it
how to mix it how to make it sound like
a [ __ ]
like i wanted to sound and um and
you know it's just kind of one one thing
just sort of led to the next and and i
feel like
when you're writing music you have to
ask yourself
you know if i'm sitting there on a piano
or with a guitar
and you know i've got a couple chords
and i know what i want to write about
you just kind of find your way through
it and you know it's like
like with anything if you practice an
instrument long enough
and you stick with it then you're there
that there's
some sort of purpose for that instrument
being in your hands in the in the in
that you've
gone as far as stressing over it and
sounding like [ __ ] and then finally you
can play something that sounds right
and you're like oh i could find a way to
take this and make it my own
so you know with with the music for the
for the church
i knew that we you know we were
listening to similar stuff
in that era obviously i'm younger than
you but but that was the [ __ ] that i
loved like
the old like like i mean the motley crew
records and
i mean cowboys doctor feel good
yesterday yeah i mean i just crashed my
[ __ ] car i was just watching an
interview with
bob rock yeah dude yeah i was just i
just couldn't believe
yeah and then you see like i always
describe guns and roads as
aerosmith on steroids oh wow if harold
smith would have done
d-ball in the 80s yeah it would right
instead of eight balls yeah if they were
done d ball diana ball
they would have been [ __ ] guns him
and i'm not taking none away from
everest
ever since one of my favorite bands of
all time i'm just now i want to ask you
questions that i don't know about
that i want people i'm gonna i'm going
in here blind
yeah yeah what is a music producer what
does he do
exactly in the studio um i think it
i mean it can mean a few different
things but in a traditional sense
like i just said i was watching an
interview with bob rock and he was
talking about
motley crue and he was talking about
look at him passing
i saw how many times i've seen that on
camera just watched that pass right
there that was the slyest [ __ ]
move i've ever seen i saw it
and i was like there's no way he brought
those for no reason
god damn it you know what i'll bring i
bring everything for a reason brother
um one of these no thank you no these
are my souls now
[ __ ] music i appreciate it to the
next level
but yeah so like so bob rock went from
producing motley crew
you know dr feelgood he went from dr
feelgood to the black album
almost i mean not not chronologically
but
he produced dr feelgood and when he got
into the studio with metallica
they were like why does it sound like
that and he was like
your guitars are tuned to e and now
you know the lowest string is e standard
tuning and he was like
motley crew tunes to d which is lower
so when they tuned down to d and they
played sad but true
it blew their [ __ ] minds that's a
great example
like what a good producer is going to do
because suddenly you're playing a song
in a higher key it's not going to feel
as heavy and with with all that weight
so the producer does not write the music
i come in and tell you
how to enhance it in a traditional sense
a record producer's job
is essentially to push an artist
to write the best music they can write
and make the best record they can make
but also i feel like it's to push them
out of their comfort zone so that they
have a creative breakthrough
you know if they're if they're if
they're thinking about things they may
not
have thought about before or if they're
exploring maybe a new style of
playing with an instrument or a slightly
new genre to bring in
to their sort of brand music
a traditional record producer is going
to push an artist
to listen to more stuff experiment more
so that they can
you know grow and and kind of evolve as
an artist what's the guy with the beard
that did jay-z rick rubin
rick rubin rick rubin he'll come in and
do
that yeah i'll enhance what you got yeah
i mean he's more
his his approach i don't know him but i
know artists that have worked with him
and
i think his approach is more um he's
kind of like the buddha
of record producers because he doesn't
really leave his studio
like if you want to make a record with
rick rubin from what i understand you go
to him
and you play him the songs and he says
you you know either whether you've got
great songs or not
and he just kind of like he sort of
mentors you through that process i don't
know that he ever even
steps foot in the studio anymore um
and it's funny because like you hear
like i mean he produced a slipknot
record
and they had a they had an experience
where they they kind of like
they weren't really into the way that he
would work but then ultimately when they
got through that record because you know
they're used to guys like ross robinson
who when they made iowa he he was like
all right you're a heavy band you're
from iowa we're going
back to iowa you're going to record this
album in the [ __ ] basement with no
air conditioner
and you're going to get down into this
thing and it was like one of their most
iconic records
but with rick rubin you know he's got
his place in malibu and he doesn't
really leave that and you know i don't
know if he was there when they were
working with him but
they were working with rick rubin and he
wasn't really coming into the studio
but that album won them a grammy so he
has a process that works
somehow magically my
what did he do like what what is he i
mean he did like the one death left now
did it yeah did he do
the first he did he did hysteria the
stereo
i know i'm not sure i'm not totally
learned on his
discography um back in black but yeah
hysteria yep i think he did something
else when i think early death
weapon yeah so he's the type of guy that
would come in
he's in the studio i mean all those big
background vocals
on def leppard that's mutlay that's his
voice
their sound on that album is mutt lang
it's crazy and what's so cool is like
however many five years ago lady gaga
put a record out called you and i
and she was like i want that deft
leopard sound so she went to mud lang
and it's got that hysteria slow
[ __ ] swing to it and his background
vocals are all over her
on that song and it's like if you close
your eyes it's like a time capsule
so in a way it's like the the record
producer is kind of like
the conjurer of all the elements that
the artist
can imagine but may not be able to to
realize on their own how does a producer
get paid
um a bunch of ways i mean
you can have you know your you can have
an upfront fee
to go into the studio um you can have an
hourly fee
uh you can you know a lot of a lot of
producers like david foster to me is
like he's the greatest record producer
of all time what did you produce i mean
somehow dude the
[ __ ] biggest songs oh like celine
dion
my heart will go on all the songs for
whitney houston on that [ __ ]
soundtrack for the bodyguard
all of pizza tara's solo [ __ ] when he
left
chicago i mean dude this guy's his
history
he he he discovered celine he didn't
discover the saline somebody else didn't
he went to canada and
they sort of passed the torch that's to
call it but
um yeah and you know michael buble
he that's dave foster he saw him at a
wedding and
the rest is history so you know like a
lot of times
when you discover new artists and you
see something in them
that maybe nobody else does you can
develop that
you can develop that artist and you're
not going to make any money at first
but if you make a record with them and
then you build this thing it's kind of
like producing a movie independently
you know you have to invest early on and
then take the film
elsewhere to distributors and so on and
so forth so it's a risk
you know it's a time investment it's a
creative investment um
but you know like if there's a number of
ways to get paid royalties and
you know i mean there's there's all kind
of revenue streams for producers but
um i mean it's certainly changing now
that physical music isn't really
much of a thing anymore vinyl is having
a new
new yeah myself serious resurgence um i
got
eight tracks sent to me this week yeah
and uh i gave to dean
some uh a church listener uh-huh so i
let
dean the eight tracker go dean let's see
if it because dean wants to do a podcast
around it
so i go dean if you want to do a podcast
just come pick it up and
give it back to me before i go back to
jersey so uh
in one day two different people thank
you whoever sent them
sent me two eight tracks and i brought
them to dean and he called me late and
he goes they sound great you know and
uh is there really i i heard that's
right
last year was the first time vinyl beat
something else out since 1980 probably
cds and yes
1987. it's wild now yeah so albums back
up on the rock
vinyl that vinyl is having a moment
right now it's it's crazy
it's been it's been boiling for the last
probably 10 years
but right now i mean i don't know what
the covet thing has done to it but
um yeah the vinyl because i think like
there's just something like uh so in
rochester we had the house of guitars
that was the [ __ ] you that's where i
bought my first guitar
that's where i bought my first album
it's amazing everything has that i had
passed on music yeah yeah yeah i had
passed on music you had
a [ __ ] three floors we go to monday
night midnight madness because all the
albums dropped on tuesdays
so monday night at midnight we get in
line
and you know for me it was more cds i
you know i was born in 82 so by the time
i was copping my own records it was on
disk
so but there's something so transcendent
about
going into the aisle finding the thing
getting into the car
unwrapping it feeling it in your hand
and putting it in and like sharing that
sort of physical
because you're creating all these like
sensory memories with you know like
the visuals and everything and you see
these you know i look at these pictures
of metallica and i'd be like
these guys like are they they're not
even real and then i'd go see them at
the hsbc arena on stage and that's the
only place
you could see them then now you go on
instagram and they're right there and
you send them a message it's like
all the magic is almost gone but i feel
like
the magic of grabbing a piece
of you know like that vinyl and pulling
the art out and looking at it and
and kind of reliving like your parents
experiences or
you know like other generations that
that that whole process
there's something so magical about it
and it creates i feel like a deeper
connection with whatever you're
listening to even if it's [ __ ]
you're like well i just wasted twenty
dollars and
you know whatever but there's just
something more about instead of clicking
on
spotify through a playlist going and
getting it and holding it in your hand
and seeing
and feeling it you know do you still buy
the physical glitch i still buy physical
movies i haven't switched over to
digital i get i do buy physical
movies i don't buy physical music okay
um
just because like when you're making i
mean
when when vinyl was like really the most
dominant format
analog recordings happening in studios
with
analog i mean this is getting really
[ __ ] techy but
a lot of a lot of artists are putting
their records out on vinyl
and they weren't they were recorded
digitally so it's kind of like
i don't know it's like if it's like if
you want to watch a film and it wasn't
shot on film
right and you want to watch it in a
theater they might have printed that
digital production
down to a 35 millimeter reel but you're
not really watching
film you're watching something that was
printed to film but if you were on set
on the day and they're shooting on that
panavision like 35 and they're checking
the [ __ ] gate
and then that real you know light candy
you can't even put light on that film
it's got to stay in a dark room the
whole time until it gets to the theater
and then you know like then you're
watching film
but i feel like the the vinyl thing
there's there's a little bit
there's a little bit of a novelty aspect
to it with regard to like you know
buying an album that was recorded
digitally on vinyl it's kind of
it's kind of counter-intuitive in a way
but i might even see these like this
sure sometimes i'll still go to like if
i'm having a bad day
i go to best buy it's like kind of a
client walk through the movie aisle
sure just it calms me down yeah and i
still see that they still have cds
yeah yeah but i don't i don't know
anyone who goes to buy so someone must
still be buying them i don't know who it
is but yeah people
people buy them i mean what's the
percentage like 80
digital 90 digital quite honestly i
wouldn't even know okay it's got to be i
mean the streamers are
obviously taking over that's it is what
it is i don't buy movies
uh for the simple reason is they don't
give me what i want in that package
sure okay you're 38 at least 32.
i'm 57. the people who listen to the
show
obviously a little younger than both
both of you guys
share the age group yep i don't buy
like okay i'll tell you right out when i
got the longest yard
they sent me a box of cds dvds
i opened it up and there was a dvd and
it was one sheet of paper
yeah that's that's it yeah that was your
presentation they didn't bring the paper
that was yeah there was no inside scoop
there was no
there's a running joke in my
neighborhood in fact two of the guys
listen to this podcast
and they we still have arguments on the
phone about uh
women and children first van halen's
women and children oh yeah right
masterpiece out yeah until you take the
poster out
it's david lee roth tied up by himself
right ripped the poster up
yeah i ripped the album up i threw it
out the window oh my god until this day
i don't want to play that that and years
later
yeah this you hear rips that they even
van halen
didn't know that david lee roth was
going to put the poster in there
so they even had a riff about it yeah
i'm just telling you that story just
sure but to tell you that i came
if i buy your 25th anniversary edition
of easy money i'm just throwing titles
out here
sure yeah i want something extra in
there i don't don't hit me with the
really
what what is it that remastered yeah
take that remastered and shove it up
your mother's ass
remastered means it's going to cost me
10 bucks and you didn't do dick
yeah we master what what are they going
to remaster
take the crickets out of the room you
buy that [ __ ]
it's remastered how many times are they
gonna remaster something
how stupid can you be america you buy
the first one that's
it the second one is that they put a
violin remastered
yeah and they take you for another 25.
they dollar you the debt while you
bought
so when i buy a remaster you got to show
me something
yeah yeah if i buy the 50th anniversary
of apocalypse now
i want to post it i want two hours to
make i want to i want a cd in there
yeah of them shooting while i'm brand
those notes on the set
you know yeah and for me
that's what happened you know i keep
saying to myself i don't know what
happened
to me with music why i lost interest in
music
i lost interest because they stopped
giving me
what i was used to sure you know yeah
again i'm
i'm 57. i [ __ ]
cut you know i believe like everybody
else when i cut
i'm furious that america cannot go to a
basketball game
the average american family can't afford
to go to a [ __ ] nick game yeah
or they got to sit upstairs and risk
getting stabbed
you know by [ __ ] whoever
my point is that you know everything is
gone you know an album is 26 dollars but
they give me less and less
so i don't want to sound like that at
all in my day no no
there's some truth to it and you got
five cents and yeah yeah
no i don't want to sound like that guy
but i lost
interest when you lost when you stopped
giving me
yeah you stopped giving me what i wanted
and then charged me double for the
product
yeah so when you were charging me 6.95
and i bought now well i don't have any
more left in here and i bought an hour
i had a sleeve to look at i had let's
take all the liner notes
the last album they put out it was well
known that
when you bought it they didn't tell you
to click
and go come here you didn't read it in
cream magazine
yeah you heard it on the streets right
that when you bought the album you took
it home
you take a sponge and you wipe the album
on and it becomes all different colors
yeah you know for a band to do that
it cost them five cents to make you that
much happier yeah right
right you know i threw away
50 [ __ ] t-shirts i've been giving
away
like all this you know we were both
moving so everybody's
we're giving away [ __ ] i give away
i've given away you know 50 of my
t-shirts
and if you look at the shirts they're
basically all black
yep and i'll tell you why i don't like
the color black that much
i like it from time to time sure but if
you
print the shirt out for your business
and it's black
yeah you're telling me you're too cheap
to pick another color yeah
yeah that's what you're telling me when
you give me a black shirt
yeah you're already telling me that
you're not [ __ ] creative yeah and
that you were too cheap
to pay the extra 50 cents right to get a
gray shirt or a purple shirt or a blue
shirt yeah
something completely different than
everybody's doing yeah you're trying to
stand out
why are you getting a black [ __ ]
shirt for yeah why are you putting out a
black shirt
right right so these are the [ __ ]
things i look at
right there i don't want to do business
with you just because you gave me a
black shirt
right there all right business is done
yeah because you're too cheap
that's 50 cents to make me happy sure
you know these are the things i look for
so the album to me
was a sad you know like you when you
went to that thing we [ __ ] delivered
papers all week
yeah right we sold nickel bags [ __ ]
yeah you know this wasn't given to us
[Music]
we're walking to 60th street and i you
know and i i've had these kids come on
the show they've been on
zoom steve avillo me and him on
saturdays we met at 10
yep and we bought a nickel bag and we
smoked a joint and then we
walked to the [ __ ] record store along
with six other and we each had plans
you're gonna buy sabotage you're gonna
buy the white album
i'm gonna buy kiss alive yep and you
went up there and then you switched
i don't really want that i i'm gonna you
[ __ ] you you
get that one god damn it now you throw
me off i want to get high
and listen to iron maiden they see dc
together you [ __ ] douchebag [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah he's not going camping with us
either you know so it was like
it was like that they just went right
back what's that that sounded like a
real fight
no that's true you're not going camping
with us either
yeah right then you get the kinks out
but you can't go from [ __ ] the hood
of the kings that's not fair
right you said you were gonna get the
who live at leeds
i i i was all ready for it's like you
told me you're gonna get chinese food
you show up in polace food
i got nothing against pierogies but you
told me you're bringing chinese food my
mouth
yeah you're ready with the chinese food
you understand me so you can't do that
[ __ ] to me yeah
who keeps sending me for that i don't
know
did you like do you guys have like if i
see something
and the the packaging is already kind of
messed up i won't get it i like
i like stuff to be probably weird like i
have weird rules about stuff like that
do you did you like like have like a
pristine collection or let me ask you a
question
what i put a [ __ ] sandwich out there
in the street unpackings and you'll eat
it so stuff with the fact that
you should all right i've given you
[ __ ] food that hasn't been packaged
in years well no one told me that you
told me it was nice
you've eaten it so snuck it off if i
don't see something
i won't buy it what about those wings
from 7-eleven i never even win
i'll walk down right now we got one left
[ __ ] you i've never even went through
this
i have not you know that you you got
rats over oh you sent him a picture the
indian call me director
the indian was like hello hello lee was
just here i heard you went to somewhere
the other day he ate six
wings i did not go to sleep and that
those little rocks i have no idea how
many goddamn tweets i'm gonna get now
stop eating those wings lee i didn't oh
the wings
[Laughter]
how dare you say those wings and then he
kept going back to the lizard place
no yeah the lizardmen the lizardme
player first of all you don't know which
place it is
next to the arabian pizza nights the
arab pizza
dough over to this corner there there's
arabian pizza yeah arabian pizza nights
you go over there pizza oh my god
it's got hummus sauce on it
the guy's like eating my pizza not a
million [ __ ] years guy right
you're [ __ ] out of your mind i'm not
eating that pizza you're [ __ ] crazy
arabian night's pizza and then it's got
like a haircut in place
it's got a black hat in place yeah black
head cut in place and that that mall on
the corner there that's taco
when i first moved here they told me at
the y don't eat that
damn they found lizard meat there that's
that's the one that you help sentencing
that's all yelp is it's communism they
saying they're sending you to go eat
where the bad food is
that's why i don't look at yelp i don't
believe it i'm sorry to interrupt you no
whatever there's no lizards in there i
haven't been there
because you ruined it and i haven't been
to the other one because john broad got
sick there
which one i'm burbank how goes one
dollar yeah
nine people got sick bleeding out of
five holes this guy goes to eat
no i don't last week well listen what
green apple dudes
what green apples no you're a green
apple juice let me just i have
green apple raised their prices up by a
dollar you know yeah no
i don't call me i went to this other
chinese place why
because green apple raised their prices
why would you go and get
inferior chinese food and save 10 cents
and you're eating some kid's cat
some kid's putting a poster together and
you're eating them watching tv
thinking you're doing a good deed green
apple don't have cats they have nothing
you don't know what they have you
haven't
i've been in that kitchen i'm friends no
you haven't just asked them
i looked right there that strength
that's the strength building man
you go to green apple we stick with
green apple we'll oil the green apple
you don't go nowhere else with a green
apple
you order from some chinese place and
nobody's even heard of it yeah
and then i tell them to go to green
apple and get it i've been the green
apple then they called me tells me
you were right the mushroom pork is good
no it's tremendous but you you wasted
your time
and got delivered and then he gets that
[ __ ] people to deliver to your house
not ubereats i only get if the
restaurant has delivery because the food
comes up
and he's telling me that he why don't
you post it he's telling me that he
don't eat nothing that the wrapping
every time he got a pizza from
from pizza bell whatever the [ __ ] that
is uh domino's
with those guys how's that packaging
how's that packaging what are you gonna
do that if i if i live in a world where
i can't trust my dominoes drivers i'm
just going to kill myself
no you have to have some sort of respect
i hope you don't all those peaches you
see they used to
pick that greasy nose and put eat the
pepperoni off it and then and then you
sit there with paula
thinking you were [ __ ] in little
italy you [ __ ]
eating some guys snotty fingers
pre-covered
i probably lost a finger by now and [ __ ]
to cover
me or the delivery guy the delivery
thank god we were talking about music oh
my god
so how did you unreal what was the first
big
artist you worked with um
well i think it would probably be like
in my 20s
when i started producing records more so
i joined a band called the sun streak
i mean we didn't we didn't do [ __ ] we
like we we sold a lot of records
on the warp tour um and they were
already a band before
i joined so they they kind of built this
thing
um locally in rochester
and uh when i joined the band we went on
warped tour and we
sold a ton of records out of the 10 are
you familiar with warped tour
no okay so warp tour is this it doesn't
really happen anymore but every summer
it's about 50 shows in
maybe like 60 days um 50 cities and it's
like 90 bands
oh [ __ ] and i mean you know early on in
the 90s when it got started you know you
would see
i mean we're talking like deftones
uh mxpx no effects you know like it was
really
rooted in the punk rock scene um but it
grew and then
uh so in 2006
the band that i was in the sun streak we
did warped tour sold a ton of records
and while we were out there we made a
lot of relationships with
other bands that were kind of like
growing and and then we toured with like
we did some dates with um chris autry
um and then we did some dates with
so many just random like rock bands but
it but it ultimately led to
you know like we did a record deal with
capital i think we sold 10 copies of
the record where we sold you know 20 000
on our own
with a label behind you you'd think that
that would change but it is what it is
um but um yeah so i mean
that was probably my first introduction
to like the actual like
next level you know where the major
label artists are sort of swinging
um and then when i left the band i did a
publishing deal with
uh a music publisher outside of new york
city
and that's when i started working with
you know artists that that were you know
like um
you know like pink or john legend or
new politics uh one of the first early
cuts that i had was on a backstreet boys
album wow um yeah yeah it was it was
cool it was cool
um and then yeah i came to la in 2013.
now but let's back up to the backstreet
boys yeah sure
i'm gonna just sorry about that how do
what do you mean you picked up a piece
with them so my manager at the time
uh was what is a he's a huge record
producer
massive records the 90s 2000s so he was
working with them
he was managing me as a producer and he
would say you know he'd reach out to me
and say
hey you know i'm going with the
backstreet boys into the studio
so we need a track that sounds you know
kind of something like this so
so he'd send me a demo of a song that
he'd started and then i would go in and
i'd play all the instruments and put it
together
at my home studio and i'd send it out
send him the instrumental and then they
would essentially record their vocals
over that
and you know that's kind of how you
break in like you sort of work through
the other guys that are sort of further
in and bigger that are in the room with
the artist
so to speak um so yeah so i you know
i've
never even met the guys i still haven't
met pink and i had two songs on her
album
i mean that one of the songs was the
title track to the record and became a
world tour and
the whole thing started in my [ __ ]
living room and she doesn't have any
idea but um
yeah sometimes it's just how it is but
it's kind of cool too you're getting
paid or credit
uh both both yes you get on that pink
song
i'll see your name oh yeah for sure no
[ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah there were two songs on that record
the truth about love and
good old days lyrics or music or both um
so i was credited as a writer and
producer okay um
i didn't write any of the lyrics she
writes all her own lyrics a lot of
artists
you know everyone's everyone's process
is different um
there have been plenty of artists that i
have written lyrics for uh but pink
writes
all her own lyrics she's very she's
she's very
um private with that process i suppose
but
so you have people who do beats yeah i
just do beats you do beats too yep
you don't give a [ __ ] the fact that i
need beats yeah
you do beats yep and then there's guys
that just write
yeah there's guys that just write lyrics
i know the guys that just write lyrics
sure
how do they make that how do they do it
well you still like as a lyricist you
still
own a piece of the copyright of the
music you know it's like bernie tobin
with elton john right he wrote every
every word that alton's ever saying
still to this day he's still yeah still
elton showed i know someone that wrote
with elton
and elton showed up and this is in the
last two years elton showed up with a
[ __ ] notebook full of bernie's lyrics
it's he just that's that's whose lyrics
he he uses he just uses burn
um you know and it's like poetry you
know he you know the like
the lyric is so much of i mean in my
opinion
it's the most important part of the song
because you can't print a melody on a
t-shirt first of all like you might
remember how a melody
is sung but the lyric is what speaks to
your soul it's what you connect with
what you relate to
you know whether or not you you hear
yourself in that song that artist
um so yeah there's there's plenty of
writers that that that
don't write lyrics that may only come up
with melodies
um because you know when you're writing
songs and and
you're sort of deep in that process a
lot of times you're just humming
melodies yourself and saying gibberish
and putting it to lyrics is a whole
different craft some people don't
necessarily do that
and then there's some lyricists that
just don't really have that musical
inclination but they know
how to use their words or how to get
down into that story that they want the
song to say
so it's weird that
with the amount of music like i'm a f
as a musician i get an f i never really
tried
i have musical rhythm because of my
blood
sure i i don't think i i would always
love to play the guitar
but writing as always when i hear
music another guy that i wanted to
always play on this podcast
but i think i would get a lot of [ __ ]
over playing him because people
never really knew the power of who he
was was el
jon yeah right the only song i could
play
on this podcast that would kind of get
them born is benny and the jets sure
i can't play my other favorite because
as far as writing was concerned for me
growing up
elton john and paul mccarthy were had
dad sure
because i saw the race they were having
i grew up at a time where
it was elton and then mccarthy fired a
grenade yeah and it was out
yeah then mccarthy fired again and got
in the mess and it was back and forth
and it was just it was there was a time
period where i it was just
paul mccartney in the wings for me yeah
is a big part of my youth
yeah john elton john there's times i
listen to out and john
and i cry yeah i mean that's big in my
it's unbelievable and people will laugh
i've never got to see him live
yeah because i don't want to rem i don't
want to see that [ __ ] yeah you want the
memories i don't want it
i get it you know i got just now talking
to you i'm thinking about
bernie toppings lyrics to
oh gina
[Music]
yeah he's got a song he came out with in
83
that is one of my favorite songs it is
his gayest song of all time
uh-huh i'm not gonna lie to nobody
you're probably gonna think i'm gay
whatever but i think it is a [ __ ]
badass song which one was it i'm still
standing
god damn he throws he goes off on that
song oh man
he goes off on that you never heard i'm
still thinking i know i haven't
but then you gotta remember from the
fifth grade
to maybe maybe fourth grade maybe third
grade
there was a time pretty well and john
just went off for five for six years bro
sure just went off yeah philadelphia
freedom yep
uh hello baby hello haven't seen your
face in a long while yeah right
oh my god the lyrics on that are
brilliant yeah what is it hello baby
hello
i haven't seen your face oh wow i don't
really i only know the classics for the
most part
uh are you still the same hoes spoiled
child
say hello hello
i gotta check it out me a really good
company
tremendous see youtube this is why we
should be able to play this [ __ ] right
now in a
ocean from a sea harmony
me i really love you and i wanna love
you forever
all that [ __ ] uh-huh you can't write
that down that was written by a gay man
then i listen to
then you gotta listen to like judas
priests yeah now you gotta listen to
jesus christ and go holy [ __ ] yeah
he was talking about [ __ ] men yeah
that's what you know
right yeah nobody burn it up you know
burn it up yeah
i know you feel the flame yeah i know
you know
these [ __ ] had no idea there
ain't no idea yeah i know you feel the
same i know you feel the flame
yeah burning deep inside of you
turning you up
breaking you out of the cold sweat
unreal
my dick and when you lose control of
your very soul
your [ __ ] your desire takes over
you'll feel the heat's weight your
answer my way look at that you
answer my weight right and suddenly
you'll know that you're burning up
you gotta dig up your [ __ ] ass
oh my god book comes out september 23rd
judas priest
the singer rob halford pre-order it i i
got no
uh he's got a book you're all gonna
fight but i can't wait to read that
[ __ ] book
hell yeah does it take anything away
from me that they
they didn't write the lyrics does that
mean anything or one's a performer one's
a writer that it's just not the same as
comedy
you know man when chris rock was putting
out all those specials it was a four-man
operation
sure that's why i told this day i
respect chris roth yeah
and i always wish that one day i had a
special that i could get
for the top comics pay them all and say
give me your best 15 minutes
sure with no ego yeah just give me your
best 15 minutes
i've had dear friends that have written
jokes that have said to me bro
i got a joke that i wrote and it's for
you
every time i see it on stage it should
be coming out of your mouth especially
josh wolfe is one of those guys
oh no chef that he'll call me and go i
really joke i tried it
it's more your your yes yep
so uh prince how many songs did prince
write i can give away
yes endless you know john lennon wrote
dude john lennon wrote fame
and elton john called them up and said
what the [ __ ]
you give him a song one of my [ __ ]
what my dog
[ __ ] and he goes give me a couple days
and he called him up and gave him benny
in the jets
you know how the [ __ ] do you do that
like yeah for a guy like me i'm sitting
there going really he just gave you many
of the jets
yeah and i know there's more to the
story always yeah there's al there's
more the story totally
he probably gave him the the lyrics and
out and put together the yeah
the piano you know but that's always
been
everybody what's you know the seven
wonders of the world you know
who built the pyramid i don't know 12
[ __ ] mongolians what are you
bothering me for
who give us a [ __ ] all right i'd give a
[ __ ] on how
they wrote uh you know uh
what's that really good out in john song
that he wrote that just killed you like
it just
tiny dancing it's just not before like
in that era and
yeah yeah it's causes with tiny dance
it's another one that
sticks a dick in your [ __ ] heart
your song yeah oh jesus yeah you're so
unreal you know did you see the movie
they made the bio picture
the old john movie i tried yeah
i love john moore itself yeah
but he lost me in that one i got you i
really like motley crue
yeah that was cool i really queen men's
and men's
[ __ ] like i watched it but i won't watch
it again sure motley crew i watched 20
times
yeah it was good i still watch miley
crew if i'm bored the whole time room
was yeah right
i just watched it maybe three weeks ago
yeah i like the part when he describes
the bands he's managed yeah the machine
gun kelly was good
as tommy lee was great but when he goes
uh
he was really good yeah that kid they
were all good he probably not they were
all really good yeah
that was a really good movie and you
know i always
a couple weeks ago people were [ __ ]
saying [ __ ] that i had said you know and
uh it's funny but nobody called me and
they're like obviously they didn't
see the molly girl movie obviously they
didn't see what was going on
yeah 30 20 years ago i'm surprised that
i'm surprised that wasn't the first
plane to be burned the opening [ __ ]
scene
yeah in the motley crew movie is a woman
squirting at a party
it's wild yeah it really is it's crazy
eats the chicks [ __ ] and she starts
working at a party
that's it's the opening scene of a
[ __ ] movie
party that's like oh yeah that's the
party you want to be
i want to be at a party with a couple
mexicans serving your hors d'oeuvres get
the [ __ ] out of here
put a black suit on talking up tight
white people are bound to get covered
eventually
what are you working on now my brother
um so i
i have uh a band solo project it's
called the bad dreamers
okay um i put a record out two years ago
um and i'm finishing my second record
right now um
so i'm putting out a song every month
until february
um we thought about you know because
when you've got like a full-length
record of music typically you know you
put a single or two out and then you put
out the album
but now you can't you know i can't tour
i can't play shows
i can't do any of that are you doing a
lot of livestock oh 100
no [ __ ] yeah yeah i you know i was under
the impression
matt this is what i was an impression i
was impression you're the guy that
if i want a song for a movie i call you
i'm that guy
really 100 yeah yep
the other day i had nothing to do
sure and i went looking for a movie just
to
and i forgot that jimmy page did the
soundtrack for it
death wish too oh [ __ ] jimmy page at the
soundtrack
what yes and it's
the creepiest [ __ ] it's perfect it's
brilliant watch it oh i gotta check that
out jimmy page did it was
bronson in that one yes oh [ __ ] i've
only seen the first one
yeah wow yeah don't even get me started
on movies i'll talk movies death wish
for three hours
death wish was great till three yeah no
no
no no i'm not even gonna give them three
no i can't
i gotta look at myself yeah i've only
seen this one the first two are good
after that
four i wanted to kill him yeah because
he was like 65 and he was chasing
people and catching them and i can't
have that i can't have a 65 year old
catching a little black kid right that's
not gonna happen that's not gonna happen
all black lives matter that's not gonna
happen all right that's not gonna happen
charles bronson 64. chasing a little boy
right
and jumps over a fence no it's not no i
can't jump over a brick
okay and i [ __ ] squad i do everything
i can't jump over
i'm telling you right now i couldn't do
it he was shooting people away from 800
yards no you're not
you can't even read the paper i can't
see without glasses how are you going to
shoot somebody 800 yards
why are you trying to sell me this
propaganda
oh it's incredible i gotta check that i
didn't know he scored that movie he
scored that movie he's
jimmy paid scored and somebody there was
another score in that you know
obviously you had the the 80s the cheesy
giorgio morata i think yeah yeah george
crawford
and uh he did a couple of those
who did the soundtrack for thief was one
of those crazy [ __ ]
oh man where whoever deceived look up
who did the soundtrack
for the movie thief was and those
soundtracks
made those 70s movies a lot of them oh
dude i mean but
for me horror film is that's
my [ __ ] well you said something in the
evening about the exorcist
yeah it's music for the exorcist yeah
well you know no one of the songs on my
new record is actually inspired by the
exorcist
we could talk about the exorcist for
three hours i've got theories about that
movie
don't get it you know it's wild and you
know what after all these [ __ ] were
getting we got raped everybody got raped
everybody in hollywood got raped
everybody's beating up harvey weinstein
what did they do to ball in the blind oh
yeah nobody's ever said a [ __ ] word
yeah and why linda blair hasn't lifted
her hands her parents should be shot
like the people who let their kids hang
out with michael jackson
it was the brazilian what they did to
her at 13 that film would she get scale
she couldn't have gotten a lot of movie
yeah a lot of money they made a freeze
they'd shot all those movies in the
freezer
yeah with the dust yeah right over here
tangerine dreams tangerine dreams
[ __ ] a tangerine dream that wasn't
right i'm telling you
all those people when those movies were
big they were all scored by
tangerine dream tangerine dreamed a
couple other movies
yeah because yeah yeah anything michael
mann did
yeah tangerine dream did yeah it's kind
of weird so that's that's what i was
doing i didn't know you had a band i'm
sorry i'm very
yeah no it's okay what happened was i
went to wikipedia my website
sure my internet went down this morning
but it went down this morning while they
were moving so yeah
i couldn't uh but i thought you just i
thought like it's
like like daily a lot of lineups
what's that tangerine dream yeah every
year they change
i'm trying to see oh yeah that's a
steady rotation
they're like uh i don't know
how to be compared to sorry they have
over a hundred things in it and they're
just geography so i wouldn't be able to
tell you
yeah no it's amazing they did 160
goddamn
that's wild you know i i
you know i score films i write songs for
tv and film
um you know that i it's sort of how i
make my living now is song writing and
and composing for picture and for series
and whatnot but
um yeah i still i i have a solo project
it's banned
it's it's it's really all me i write all
the songs i produce them
play the majority of the instruments
until the new record i've got my
my geyser on it now but um but yeah
um i'm putting out a new song every
month through the rest of
through february um just because you
know we can't get out and tour we can't
promote the music in a proper way
so we're trying to stretch it out and do
something different and put out a new
song every month and then at the end
we're gonna we're gonna release a vinyl
you know an actual physical copy with
the full record and
replace the skin flute if you ever need
them to come in hey
we play every
but it's kind of cool i have a buddy who
does
i'm blanking on the term now but he also
he also produces
and there was a movie a year or two ago
that the girl kept reliving the same day
and her phone would ring and sure yeah
yeah it's called happy
happy death day he wrote the jingle just
for the ringtone oh cool
yeah you know that yeah that's a gig
yeah like
unbelievable
that's intellectual property i mean
that's you know that's a copyright
yeah it's crazy i mean there's so many
ways
to monetize music
because music is used in so many you
know like a ringtone in a film
they need a sound and it needs to be
original they can't use the apple one
they can't use
the google one those are they own those
so they need an original sound you know
there's so many the interview different
ways day
with uh whoever wrote ghostbusters
all the music dude one of the best
stories
that's for a theme song ever you want to
say it uh
no please no no i i forget the whole
thing yeah it was amazing yeah i'm glad
yeah yeah what's the guy's name
um the dude's name was because it wasn't
ghostbusters at first it was called they
called it something else
ray something yeah i think that was his
only song like he was a one-hit wonder
yeah
but he really was a lot more they just
interviewed him
they just interviewed ray parker
what else is he responsible for um i
mean that's definitely his biggest
let's see what he's got on
ghostbusters a woman needs love
yeah they only said that i don't know
crazy it's crazy that you would get that
like look okay i do stand up yeah you
know i do stand up and you crack jokes
and
yeah there's a medium for it if somebody
puts it on youtube or
netflix or somebody puts it on uh
whatever but even like watching the
bomba
when they're [ __ ] in the car and
often they play richie's music on yeah
right
richie valens and you listen to the
music
the feeling it changes everything it
changes ever i can't imagine yeah
i couldn't even when i listen to myself
on radio it's [ __ ] sure
i'm talking about a song that you
started with and all of a sudden you're
going you know i can't imagine
being aerosmith sure getting in a car
and dream on which is played every day
in america
is on the radio and you're numb to it
but you think about for just one second
how that all started
yeah with you just playing two chords on
the [ __ ] camera just
tinkering around your wife just left
here yeah you're looking at the table
there's bills on the table
you're in no danger of paying paying
them yeah you're at your lowest point in
your
life yeah and those two chords on a
piano yeah man and all of a sudden
you think of like yeah they're lucky if
they think they're going to get paid
dream on yeah right i'll send you like
try
hits you like a truck and it just hits
you and it's
it's got to be a [ __ ] phenomenal
feeling
like i said i'm at the you know
i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want i go
back to law school or whatever
i just i gotta raise a [ __ ] kid and
that's my biggest concern
but if i could do it all over it again
i wish i would have had the i didn't get
a guitar because i knew the cocaine
would make me pawn it
like i just knew yeah you know what i'm
saying there's no reason there was no
reason to buy a guitar because i was
only going to own it for two weeks
i was going to go it was going to be in
and out of that pawnshop i knew this
going in
i know who i was at the time so i knew
if i bought a 500
guitar yeah it's going to be in a porn
shop every time i get in a hole or
eventually
so that's why i never committed to music
yeah but if i ever have a chance to come
back and get another life
i'm going to have to go music it's in me
it's yeah yeah then
no it absolutely let it out you know
yeah and even now i'm like let me just
try to write a song like i would like to
just write a song one time
yeah just write lyrics fail miserably
but that's what it's all about man
like i feel like
i i mean i i just think about like my
journey i mean there's so many
songwriters
and producers and composers that have
achieved
so much more than me but here i am in
los angeles
i'm 38 i pay the bills making music
and i think like you know
it's just a series of failures that lead
you
down your path because you nobody really
knows
what they're [ __ ] doing when it comes
to a creative
endeavor you just try [ __ ] and [ __ ] up
and then you move on and you either
decide to do it again
or you quit and it's the people that
[ __ ] up
over and over and over and somehow
figure things out along the way you
never let me make something
crystal clear for anyone that's
listening that has any
inclination to pursue something creative
anyone in their ear tell them they can't
[ __ ] do it
the only thing that you know for sure is
gonna happen
is that you're just gonna keep making
mistakes but
those mistakes might point you in the
right direction of the right mistakes to
make
because even if you're you know if
you're
i don't know i i wouldn't even know who
to compare it to but but anyone that
says that they've got it figured out
they're lying i did
all the wrong things to get to the right
place
that's right yeah okay i went to prison
you know i i got you know i was the
black sheep of the family and my family
um you know i'm not proud of these
things sure
but i i'm who i am today yeah you know i
i'm doing this patreon and now i'm
getting different type of messages
you know and i've noticed the last two
weeks
it's 19 to 23
that struggle right now they're really
really really struggling these kids
yeah they're either pre-college or
getting out of college
if you're pre-college right now what's
going through your [ __ ] mind
what's going through your mind yeah you
worked all your life you did everything
now you're not even going to live the
college experience yeah there's no frat
parties it's
wild yeah definitely take some time how
was there not going to be football this
year
has anybody wrapped their heads around
it when we got the announcement
a week ago that yeah there's not going
to be no college fun like the acc and
somebody
big ten i don't know i think the acc is
still on i think a couple of them are
playing but
regardless of it yeah do you understand
the impact that that's going to have
billions of dollars to a community and a
college do you understand
yeah the impact when you go on wikipedia
texas a m and see what their indominus
for football you know that's that's
you know if you know sponsors like i
lived in boulder
yep so i understand the sponsor the guy
who runs his business donates a certain
amount
gets season tickets trustees sponsors
they they you know
they whatever uh stealing
without a gun that's what it's called
robbing you without a gun
you've given me 25 of your business so
you could be part of my [ __ ] team
so i could let you in the locker room so
you could sit behind us
you could travel and you could have a
social life that you all dressed
together in red and
traveled nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong with being
an alumni association you know they have
all those
you know who do you think keeps these
[ __ ] programs alive the boosters
your booty that's like boosters yeah
you know so yeah you look at all this
and and those boosters
are boosters because every year they
know that the stark quarterback
is going to give him a football with an
autograph on it and he can show his
[ __ ] friends not entertain that
yeah i don't even think about it what
about the coaches who make like millions
of dollars a year
what about the teams that travel i mean
this is just this is going to be
a club the college football i'm going to
be honest with you guys i saw a couple
things
coming you guys know that we've talked
about them on the show
i didn't see college athletics canceled
yeah right
i did not i figured they were gonna
figure it out how the [ __ ]
you know harvard you better get your
[ __ ] helmets on you better get your
helmets on harvard
because college football has to play
this year harvard
so you better go back tomorrow and get a
vaccine i don't give a [ __ ] what it is
a helmet whatever the [ __ ] you got a
special mask
something because how can you not play
college [ __ ] sports till spring
you think i want to see [ __ ] notre
dame against nebraska in april go [ __ ]
yourself
go [ __ ] yourself we weren't meant to see
you will throw off our [ __ ] time
clocks
it's like we'll all be living in alaska
you think we're [ __ ] now
let me see if football gets thrown in
april you're gonna have a heart attack
why because it never happens it's
supposed to be in the fall it's a
you're not supposed to [ __ ] play
football in april
you gotta have the weather the whole
thing the whole thing yeah what the [ __ ]
is that you're gonna wait for the spring
and [ __ ] me up
like i'm not [ __ ] up didn't i just
wake up the other day and say have a
good weekend yeah didn't i just say that
on monday
monday morning monday morning have a
good [ __ ] weekend
and now you're gonna throw football away
at me
and i'm really gonna be not lost now oh
my god what do you think you do when you
wake up
[ __ ] up on a saturday morning in a
hotel room from doing comedy
college football that's true but there's
no comedy either so
unreal well [ __ ] the long [ __ ]
boy how the [ __ ] is that not gonna be
college football
jesus that pissed yeah everybody's
pissed
yeah but what are you gonna do and
that's why we need
music now yeah right more than ever
listen man i
when i told him heaven tonight he almost
[ __ ] his pants
nobody listens to the cheap changes
this is what's been good about this
pandemic that i got to
rediscover my music again yeah like real
like again elton john i want to know
john thing one night that i found myself
on the floor crying ready to blow a
[ __ ]
yeah you know yeah holding my own knees
ready to blow a man
when you watch him play at dodger
stadium
in that crystal-covered dodgers uniform
when he was doing all that she took over
new york yeah like in 1973 one time
i was a kid i was still living in new
york city and i remember the traffic
he just sacked new york second guy to do
that was a man by the name of michael
jackson he just [ __ ] new york up
yeah right in 84 yeah 83 then when
thriller came out it was
over it was over when michael jackson
did the garden
those streets were shut down jack yeah
those streets the tri-city was out
they were just out when michael jackson
came to your town you just went down
there
wow the earliest home video that i have
my dad died earlier this year and i was
going through i'm very sorry thanks man
um i was going through all the vhs tapes
and the oldest tape i could find where i
was around
is me [ __ ] moonwalking on christmas
eve
by the christmas tree just shuffling
around to thriller
my mom's blasting it in the battle three
years old i can barely spit people have
no idea
people have no idea like and how they
did it was
brilliant yeah how they did the whole
michael jackson thing
unreal was brilliant and i was there to
judge to see the whole thing
like it was him with his five brothers
then his voice matured then they pulled
them
away and they did an album called the
best of michael jackson
that nobody even knows about i had to
even tell miss pat
remember that at the end of it or
something with the dub on it
i go when black people don't know
african americans don't know about
now that's when you know the album
they took barry gordy took michael
jackson he was 14
15. did ben you know yeah
it's a great album the best of michael
jackson wow it's got a song
i did i i remember the title but i
didn't know it came before oh
yeah it came okay it came when he
right that last album is moving
violation
okay which is a great album yeah then
jermaine left
because he married barry gordy's
daughter okay
jermaine left and put on put on a
uh solo out let's get let's go out
tonight let's go dancing
yeah in the morning night [ __ ]
terrible remember when
chris rock went off on him he said he
was greasy jermaine jackson
a greasy [ __ ] i don't know
i'm gonna have to look that up and let's
let's go to the candlelight oh baby
that's going out tonight well that way
that sucked
so [ __ ] michael came out with
and i get i think that i think the
jackson five this they called themselves
the jacksons
that was it that michael came out with
off the wall
yeah which was pretty [ __ ] good at
81.
and i went to see that at the garden
with this dude named christy lorenzo god
rest his soul
and it was three quarters empty whoa
shut up the cop was updated yeah right
the top was empty
like michael jackson hadn't grabbed
people yet like they didn't really know
and then in 19 in the winter of 82
he did the motown's 25th anniversary
and that's the first time that
[ __ ] walked yeah yeah
yeah on a sunday night in america yeah
and there was no
internet yeah bro houses were just
blowing up yeah
boom boom what the [ __ ] is that and i
slept through it
and it made like the front page of
newspapers the next day
like that was the biggest news did you
know i pretend you saw i don't know
no i had to like suddenly have that
great show somebody showed me like a
week later or something like that like
they had taped it on something
i think it was vhs or something but you
had to see it that's crazy
but people went i remember like going
out that night and people actually
stayed home to watch it
and then went out and they were like
people were coming out going did you see
michael jackson
holy [ __ ] like he just hit you with that
first
and then they were starting to and the
thriller was
right a little bit of thriller yeah he
was just giving it to you little by
little dog
little by little yeah he didn't release
that out you go out to a club
you'd be dancing to the club on some
coke and [ __ ] yeah
michael jackson came up and he made that
film that thriller
where he turned into a werecamera he
just said he just [ __ ] he just finger
banged you to death
it was wise because it was thriller and
then something else you say oh and then
he released the video then he released
the album
and then they did a world tour and then
the jacksons released an album
so it was called victory and then they
all went out together they just [ __ ]
it up
they [ __ ] it up so much this is what
they were doing you ready this account
like everybody says this economy was
booming well
listen to this economy [ __ ] the giants
the meadowlands in 84. ready
yeah nine days of michael jackson yeah
that's insane
nine nights of michael jackson and then
bruce came in were born
in the usa yeah right nice
then bon jovi would come in i don't
think bon jovi no about joey didn't bust
away 87
really yeah right it was it was those
two
18 nights and what is that like half a
million people
i mean dot the giant stadiums was 70 000
and me and my man venery the freeholder
he got tickets
everyone has a title i love it real
he's a free holder that's my boy
i hit him up yesterday i said i need my
job i'm trying to get into the
i'm trying to get back into the you know
when you got out of prison you're gonna
be the driver now
i'm trying he he keeps laughing at me
but he doesn't know i'm gonna start
writing letters
the daily news i'm gonna get that job
listen man i'm happy that you took the
time out i'm happy that
you wrote a great intro to our song yeah
he's going for the last year
if i start something i will contact you
i won't either
yeah you know i'm in put something
whatever it is for me whatever yep
um you're a great guy man this is a
great appreciate
time with you just talking getting to
know you yeah man hell yeah
it's just a weird [ __ ] time you know
people just yeah
i'm happy that you're still able to uh
do your music now what's the name of
your band again the bad dreamers no this
is a solo project
yeah you play every instrument um up
until this record that i'm finishing
right now i was playing every instrument
like with your intro i played all that
[ __ ] on guitars and all that no
[ __ ] yeah yeah um but yeah so with the
bad dreamers
i mean listen if you like duran duran or
nine inch nails or peter gabriel it's
it's very much reminiscent of that um
and
uh yeah you can find it everywhere that
is available spectrum though
yeah when people send me emails like hey
listen to my band
they're very black savagey very
uh some guys some guy sent me
some music the other day yeah and i look
at everything
this i almost hit myself against the
computer because it was like a grateful
dead dead
it was like the grateful dead had died
yeah right and they just propped them up
and played oh geez
they were young kids but i think the
mets got him already something oh my god
i don't know where the kid sent me the
video from was i i hope it was a joke
i hope i hope for his thing i don't be
done listening right now
i hope he is because he sent me some
terrible [ __ ] music man
it was usually i get some pretty
interesting [ __ ]
some of it is not up my alley but i'm
still impressed with it sure yeah this
looks like a band i think out of west
virginia
oh boy oh boy they better go right back
into that coal mine
coming to the mountains i gotta spray
the mic when you talk they were bad
i think it was a joke i swear to god man
i get some [ __ ] sometimes from people
that
people think like i'm like a judge i'm
[ __ ] the voice sure yeah
i swear to god yeah i would watch that
show
what you as a judge on one of those i
have no time for that
who am i to judge somebody yeah who the
[ __ ] am i to tell somebody
that music is great point i can't listen
to
i can tell you if i love something if i
get you know i could tell you it's like
that episode of the
sopranos and christopher did you ever
see that
man when he hit the guy with the guitar
and he gave him a method
here go shoot up um he takes the
record to the old man the jew as yeah
and hesh tells him it's not a hit you
know yeah i'm one of those guys
i could tell you if it's going to catch
yeah sure yeah you know but i can't tell
you if it's good or not
yeah you know if you got something
that's catchy yeah you just know you
like
i'm an old man i know sure you know like
this summer
we don't get summer hits anymore yeah
yeah right
what was the summer hit this year yeah i
mean if you're listening [ __ ] people
dying on facetime
yeah right that's the summer ahead of
the summer
that's the summer
every year you know the last summer hit
the greatest impact summer hit i've had
in my life you're going to freak out
what song destroyed the summer
some girl ah
miss you by the stones
is that him i've been holding that so
long
girl i miss you oh yeah
that was the last huge
summer song before that it was
peter frampton oh what's grampton comes
alive
when i was a kid bro there wasn't a
block you didn't hit
that frampton if you played anything
else but frampton you'd get a backhand
you better prank them on doug frampton
never did anything else after that
you even notice that
nobody ever went to see him again he
came alive one time
that was a one-time performance for
peter franklin great album though
wow great you know but my summer my
summer songs
uh one of my greatest summer songs
first time i made out with a girl the
eagles one of these knights
oh he's 75 what are you [ __ ] nuts
right well he's crazy all night
we're gonna find out pretty mama what
turns out
that night what's going on
oh yeah was that banter in that stuff i
don't know what a panther yeah
like so we were talking about money
earlier
for someone who did that who did like a
one-hit wonder yeah can they
survive like maybe not live in the hills
but could they have a one-bedroom
apartment
for the rest of their lives if they're
sung listen i don't know
if you wrote a hit song back when
records
and tapes and cds for selling and you
were the only writer
and that [ __ ] went number one on the hot
100.
you could pretty much do whatever the
[ __ ] you want wow
yeah and that's when there was all three
genres
when you could get it you know like if
if i mean
this the record companies are making
so much money from streaming right now
maybe even more than they were
during like the physical copy
you know boom you know like the 90s the
late 90s was when
i think cds were at an all-time high
2000 2001
um but the but the major labels are
making just as much if not more
now off of streaming than they were then
but the artists are getting shafted
in those deals but if you were
a songwriter with a hit song and you're
the only writer a lot of times now you
see a lot of
different songwriters on songs credited
six or seven writers which is kind of
it's sort of weird to think about when
you have that many songwriters for one
song
but you know it is what it is sometimes
there's that many writers on a tv show
or a film or whatever
um but yeah you can uh back when
physical copies were selling if you
wrote a hit song you were the only
writer you were
you were doing just fine what about just
performer like
i don't know i like like we just did the
thing on back in black
sure you hear you can turn that on any
country in the world you're going to
hear that
on a rock station yeah every day yep
like
are they are they making like a million
a month like what are they like um i
mean
with classic hits like that that are
just gonna stay at radio
deep six figures a year wow
for sure yeah that's crazy for sure
if not i mean internationally it
probably is somewhere in the seventh
probably i mean you know i'm a cuban jew
i'm on top of my sag dudes so yeah right
i have a page on my side where i can
tell yeah how much money you're going to
send me every week yeah right
it tells you sunday at six o'clock what
time do i log in
sunday at 5 59. you don't see it
again i want to see the switch come up
right there right in front of my eyes
yeah
it's so funny you can tell i'm at the
end of my rope like i'm getting checks
for a dollar twenty one
seven fifteen oh man there's like four
forty three but they still better show
up in there
they better show up yeah right it's when
they stopped showing up yeah my wife was
like yeah but they're all dolly go [ __ ]
you put ten of these together we got ten
that's a [ __ ] sandwich
yeah you know i used to throw away the
thirty cent ones not anymore [ __ ]
yeah cash every cent gas is 335 a gas
tank i put
all those quarter checks i use them
those people that send me those quarter
checks are like he's not going to use it
[ __ ]
you got the wrong [ __ ] i felt
like 1800 checks
going through my mail they're all for
like eight dollars or whatever but
they're sure
expired i'll have to see if i can cash
them for what
i don't know someone just do like like
when you cancel an insurance plan and
they send you back
six bucks oh yeah like little i have
like
i have like eight i have like 18 bucks
and like four checks
yeah rip them up they're not going to
give you by the time you get them in the
mail and they're going to even [ __ ]
it's like sagging sag won't even rep
like if you lose your side check
they tell you call us back in 90 days
yeah that's it
make sure that we didn't send it on the
wrong horse
i look at the [ __ ] date it gets sent
and i'm by the mailbox that attention
i'm watching the mailman park i'm
watching them go from house to house
because if my checking in that batch
let's go back to all those houses and
see if
you gave it to somebody else because my
[ __ ] sag said it was coming on this
day that's all i know all right that's
all i know is cocktail
whatever the [ __ ] so you better have my
check
i remember i had the filipino male the
mailman
the one that me and ralphie had he would
like tell me from far away like
like he would look when he was taken out
like i would just have to whistle
and he would go not today nothing today
and i would run upstairs what the [ __ ]
is the check you motherless [ __ ]
i sent it on friday no you didn't it
would have been here today
oh i bet you like even smell the bag in
the world checking it
well i used to get pissed i used to lose
my what i was doing blow and you told me
my check was going to be there on friday
that [ __ ] better be on friday
because i already have plans you see
what i'm saying
you can't cancel i'm not talking plans
with your girlfriend to go to dinner
i'm talking i'm buying an 8-ball and i'm
trying to check out my hotel hollywood
bed
and i'm going to put coke rocks in her
ass you can't cancel that [ __ ] hotel
hollywood
right there with them they saw lizard
meat right there that's all
i've been there that's a good little one
hotel hollywood yeah
90 days and then you have to call them
then it takes another 90
days so you might as well just lose the
[ __ ] check yeah
now i'm moving oh i'm gonna get robbed
to death
they don't have sag in new york yeah
they got sag in new york within the
switchy
and the switchy rui oh they're gonna
attack those checks
yeah surprise you're not gonna stop by
the sag office one more time before you
leave bro who do you think you're
dealing with
what's going on right after we leave
here i'm going to think we're doing an
afternoon one
i'm going down monday nice and early to
see what's behind that basket
because i guarantee there's some after
ones too see sag murray's raptors now
you don't even know what's out there now
they're really stealing from you
you know you're in the union no not yet
what the [ __ ] are you waiting for uh the
right job right
yeah okay yeah most of the work that
i've done up up to this point has been
non-union stuff um but uh
yeah i'll eventually i'll joint sag and
get my stupid voice on something
okay i think
but i am in them in a musician's
musician's union what what
is there a writer's union like a
composer's union um is there a producer
no you know what's what's so [ __ ] up
about the film industry
is that the only component of
filmmaking that doesn't have a union are
the composers
it's crazy you would think by now
that they would have some sort of a
union but they don't
um and you know for whatever reason i
really don't know what what it is
um i'm sort of just at the front of that
journey in
the the film composing side um but uh
yeah there's no union for film composers
there is for
musicians for performance you know if
you're playing guitar like
i played guitar for a dude on regis
years ago and i got paid through the
union for that or you know like in new
york
yeah yeah we use philbin yeah yeah i i
got the rest of this always
rest in peace man yeah it was it was
august of 2011
right right before he left the show i
got to meet him and she was just cool
you've had a pretty interesting life as
well it's been cool man yeah
making it happen yeah just uh yep and
uh you're gonna hit a home run
eventually you know yeah we'll see full
time grammy nominated
yeah we'll see yeah you're throwing
enough spaghetti against the wall but i
like what you said earlier
and uh yeah the way you encourage people
and that's that's what people want to
hear i mean
especially now you know we're in a tough
void right now for young guys
yeah and uh what do you tell a young
musician right now
that they can't play live music
[ __ ] this is the time to learn how to
write you know i mean
i'm doing a thousand things i'm not
writing copy
i'll tell you that right now sure i'm
not writing any comment yeah there's no
comedy coming out of my life yeah we
[ __ ] around here
trying to goof around and he tells me
how did you come up with that you know
uh but
but uh their dad called him up and i was
high and i was thinking about how
americans have lied to us for years
dracula is really gay
but they didn't want you to let you know
that he was gay for sure when i was
i read it years ago that dracula was gay
anyway it doesn't matter
he asked me how i came up with i don't
even know he goes how do you come up
with there's a lot more to that theory
that
as a horror guy i know that he's he had
to be gay
yeah 100 he had a big game and they made
him
dracula [ __ ] everybody [ __ ] men
female you don't give a [ __ ] you know
every week
yeah he gave dick to everybody not for
other man but then the americans said
[ __ ] it only
women he could only wipe women in the
net yeah that's [ __ ] yeah the
western
take on dracula's way different than
what he was waiting for he used to bite
men in the neck
yeah and you had to stick your finger up
his ass and he let go
like a pit bull that's why when a pit
bull bites you you got to stick your
finger up his ass
and he breaks the grips a lot of people
don't know that we're dropping
technology on a tuesday
i'm saying on a wednesday i'm sorry
wednesday
the 17th blurs day every day the 19th
of [ __ ] day in august whatever the
[ __ ] it is listen
i want to thank you for coming on and
taking the time and thank you for having
me man for doing the jingle for us it is
[ __ ] i mean
first time i heard it my [ __ ] [ __ ]
got hard
you hit it right in the head and it was
just weird that
from listening and from i learned
something from you doing that
yeah you know how predictable i was i
learned that i am predictable
i don't think it's predictability i
think i mean dude listen
i'll give you my version of how that
happened so
and i'll try to keep it brief because i
know we're wrapping it up we're here i
just don't want to
so top of the year like i said my dad
died earlier
february 7th i mean my dad was the
he's the only reason i had a shop doing
any of this [ __ ] he supported me
without wavering my mom did too but but
when my parents split i stayed with my
dad
and um yeah so he died on february 7th
and it was
it was really big um i went back to
rochester we
my sister and i did the thing i get back
into town
and um february 22nd
the dog that i came out here with died
in a freak accident
i've had him for seven years um my uh my
ex
and i who's my best friend julie page
actually that's julie
welcome to church [ __ ] that's
julie page everybody show some love
um yeah we moved out here with this dog
and he was you know just like such an
awesome
part of our lives and uh two exactly two
weeks later
um he uh he died in a freak accident
february 22nd
and then march comes around and this
coronavirus hits
and you know typically when you go
through something
painful like that you know you have to
let those feelings move through you but
it's also good to be out and be social
and be with friends
but you know with the pandemic you just
gotta sit at home
in your thoughts so i was at home
and um really just i mean just going
through
this [ __ ] that just happened in february
and um
it was really i mean i i don't think i
touched an instrument
and then uh it's crazy man it's just
crazy how it works
i open up your podcast one day and i
hear you come on
and you go we can't do the music anymore
and as soon as i heard you say it i was
like
i can do something about that i knew
it was the first time i felt inspired
really the whole year and for whatever
reason i did i just sat down
and it happened and i hit up matt i know
i mean
matt's he met basically moved out here
with me we didn't live together we lived
together for two years
in 1516. um but we're both from new york
we're both from rochester
and uh i hit i had shelter up and i was
like dude um
i heard what happened i want you to just
give this to him
uh because i felt like i had to just do
it
and just get it out so you know you
asked me earlier
what i would say to somebody who's
you know maybe at the start of that
creative journey
right now or listening at home um
pay no attention to this pandemic
you gotta get into the [ __ ] that
inspires you
and you gotta find that spark and you
gotta throw the gas on it and you just
gotta get to work man it's work
you gotta just do it and you can't let
anyone else get in your ear
and tell you that you shouldn't do it
that you're not going to be able to do
it that it's a numbers game that it's
competition
your competition is all upstairs it's
all you
you're going to make your thing no one
else can make it for you
and um yeah i mean that's my two cents
man
i love you brother i love that stuff yes
i love that me saying that because i
didn't know what i was gonna do
yeah you know i love music i love music
sets the tone then that
song sent the tone of the podcast so
i really want to thank you from the
bottom of my heart i'm sorry about your
dog and your dad
no i appreciate it i can't imagine what
you're going through but uh
and we tried topic music years ago we
just did it for like three weeks and
you like i don't i don't care yeah right
it's it's at the tone so yeah
you did good man thank you very much i'm
sorry that
wrong things had to happen for the right
thing to happen but that's life dude but
that's [ __ ] life yeah
that's that's how it goes uh you gotta
take the hand you dealt with and do the
best with it
i don't know what i'm gonna do you know
i'm gonna
i'm gonna pack my bags and move and
lee's going to milwaukee and he's gonna
go spend time with his mom
and his dad and uh i'm going back to
jersey and i'm gonna
put my daughter in school yep get her
settled settle myself and
take a couple weeks from this and uh
i don't want to reboot the church sure
because
we did it yeah we did the church yeah
yeah
what i'm saying like the church with the
church i'll do a zoom with lee
we will get we'll do a surprise room and
talk to some people
scott cunningham and the [ __ ] crew
you know yeah la lingus and stuff yeah i
think the church for now
i think i uh i'm sick of booking guests
yeah i think this is the hardest thing
i've ever done in my life wow
this was the hardest thing i ever had to
do so if i ever do a podcast again
it's going to be something with a screen
something like that because
the guest thing was just too hard sure
it was just too hard i
i sent out thousands of emails yeah
thousands of emails yeah it's a ton of
from pete rose to yep
i took chances with everybody because
you know yeah the worst thing they could
say to you is no
sure uh some people just said no which i
appreciated
some people told me to go [ __ ] myself
you know but uh
i think that was the hardest thing and i
think the pandemic
was when i really realized that i had to
do something quick because
i was real i was i was getting the same
rotation that the other people sure it's
the same guest
yeah so eventually they're not gonna go
anywhere yep i've already been telling
stories for [ __ ] eight years
yeah they know every [ __ ] story i say
so whatever my next chapter is
uh and it really is leaning towards
music
yeah all the numbers are leaning towards
music
and movies yeah because i've been
watching little clips online lately
and i see how passionate i get and then
people will hit me back going
dog you're hitting on nail with that
actor or whatever
you really plucked it you should expose
that guy a little more and
maybe get him on the podcast i can't get
him on the podcast of course yeah
i was dying to get diego luna on here
sure his publicist told me to go shoot
myself you know so
i would do diego luna a world of good if
he came on the podcast because
i watched all his vulnerabilities on
narcotics as an actor you know so
uh but that was just the toughest thing
of this yeah it wasn't doing the podcast
it wasn't the content
it was getting the guests that could
just
come in and be themselves yeah that's
really tough yeah man you know i'm not
going to let him in i don't want you to
come in to promote your tv show yeah
right
i didn't like people coming in from
what's gonna have a conversation i
wanted people to
come and have conversations yeah and
that's what happened and then you know
it turned into something else so
uh this was my open mic for comedy chef
i did two years with felicia and edward
lee yep
and i learned all the ins and outs you
know of
yeah how it works and i'm really proud
[ __ ] yeah i'm really proud oh yeah we
we picked up on something that was
completely new and yeah
i learned how to do strategies with it
and how to
yeah ads and how to you know it was
really an interesting journey
i want to take a break yeah and come
back with something that i'm really into
yeah and just uh end it so you'll be
hearing from me again brother you got it
but i thank you you really
hit it on the [ __ ] head awesome thank
you and i said what's your [ __ ]
problem
sucker i didn't need those wings
goddammit i didn't eat those wings yes
you did
yes you did real quick i want to talk to
you about something over the weekend
if you got instagram i put a little
[ __ ] uh video up
listen the church is brought to you by
manscape i love
manscape i love it i love shaving my
balls with it
the the lawnmower 3.0 they're great
they're great but manscaped is dedicated
to helping you take care of
all your hair from butt to nut but now
they released the shears 2.0 nail kit
listen you guys know you're wearing
sandals your feet
are [ __ ] disgusting and i'll tell you
what i'm an immigrant
if you're an immigrant do not wear
sandals your feet are disgusting
i do not want to see immigrant feet that
don't have cream on them
nobody wants to see your [ __ ] fungus
toenail all right i got a fungus toenail
i grind it once a month and i smell the
dust it's [ __ ] horrible but forget
about all that
no more personal stuff the shears is the
perfect add-on to the lawnmower
once you've got your skin your stinky
[ __ ] ball heads in orders
you got to make sure that your hands and
your feet are as smooth as uncle joey's
nut sack
you got to trim your fingernails and you
got to cut your cuticles why
because when you finger bang somebody
you could rip one of their [ __ ]
interior walls with your [ __ ] loose
nail you got to clean your fingers and
[ __ ] like that you gotta be
you gotta take care of your hands what
do women look at they look at your
fingers
to see if you manicure your fingers and
how dirty your fingernails are
they look at your teeth to see if you're
just a disgusting animal like me
like if a woman looks at my teeth she's
like that [ __ ]
eats ass he's got that brown tint in his
teeth
anyway i'm talking about the shears 2.0
features a four-piece luxury nail kit
with tempered stainless steel slash tip
tweezers and rounded point scissors
and clippers and a medium grit nail file
perfect
to bust out any [ __ ] prison now a
medium grit nail file
to round off the rough edges that's what
happens when you finger a chick
you slice a little monkey with your
fingernail you don't want to slice those
chicks monkey that's a complete
different charge that's a complete
different episode of law and order
do me a favor while you're there pick up
the perfect package 3.0
and get your balls in order listen
september's upon us
you got to stop wearing white or start
wearing white and you got to trim your
balls you got to be ready
it's [ __ ] there's no football so now
you got to come at them from different
directions
and you want to be prepared you want to
have let's say you do trim your [ __ ]
nut sack
and your dick is looking good and you
take your shoes off you get those
disgusting feet now what
you want to look good from head to toe
and that's why
[ __ ] manscape.com is here so do me a
favor
get the lawnmower 3.0 a waterproof
cordless body trimmer
plus the crop preserver and the crop
reviver
and if you subscribe you'll get a new
blade refill
every three [ __ ] months who's going
to take care of you like that
manscape.com that's who
sorry about the corona get 20 off
and free shipping with code church20
that's church20 at manscape.com that's
20
off with free shipping at
use manscape.com church 20 right write
it down right now
chur ch capital letters 20
20 that's a good number summer is here
it's trying to tempt him up
with manscape whether it's your toes
your nose hairs
or your ball sack go to manscape.com
right now
and press in church20 and i'm going to
get you 20
off and free shipping do yourself a
favor
get the right tools for the [ __ ] job
i want to thank my man david
i want to thank the christ killer and i
want to thank you [ __ ] for
listening
and for having our back don't forget the
parties going on over at patreon.com
joey i'm trying my best and that's it
and that's that we got no tour dates is
it joey or joey diaz joey diaz who the
[ __ ] knows i don't give a [ __ ]
press whatever the [ __ ] you want in
there knock yourself out i love you guys
have a great weekend
we'll be back monday morning tip top
magoo
avoid the [ __ ] cobit all right stand
away crowds i love you [ __ ]
stay black kick this [ __ ] muley
[Music]
you